yesterday morning John Brennan the CIA
director that served under President
Obama from 2013 to 2017 testified before
the House Intelligence Committee as part
of their investigation into Russia and
the Trump campaign now before we get
into it does anyone still feel that the
house Intel committee has any
credibility at this point in their
investigation of Trump Russia I
certainly don't so this was powerful
testimony but yes it was in front of a
committee riddled with scandals like
when former committee chair Devin Nunez
was running to the White House to tell
Donald Trump what the committee had
lunatic ideologues like trey Gowdy
asking bogus questions at that committee
hearing after hearing but okay that's
where John Brennan testified let's focus
on the testimony for now John Brennan
who is the person that the Trump
administration often cites as having
said hey Brennan said there's no
evidence of Trump Russia collusion
Brennan has since walked back that claim
and said he cannot say with certainty
whether there is evidence proving or
disproving collusion between Donald
Trump and Russia and the key point is
that while Brennan is not necessarily I
don't know on anyone's side for lack of
a better term he's definitely not
defending Trump here the way that the
White House has been portraying him to
be some great defender of Trump being
squeaky clean yesterday former CIA
director John Brennan told the house
Intel committee but during the 2016
election he was briefed on intelligence
that showed quote contacts and
interactions between the Russian
government and members of the Trump
campaign we knew that right we knew that
there were communications between Russia
and members of the Trump campaign but
Brennan yesterday emphasized the
interactions multiple times and I was
sort of enlightened to hear how
concerned he was about this take a
listen to what John Brennan had to say I
encountered an aware of information
intelligence that revealed contacts and
interactions between Russian officials
and US persons involved in the Trump
campaign
that I was concerned about because of
known Russian efforts to suborn though
such individuals and it raised questions
in my mind again whether or not the
Russians were able to gain the
cooperation of those individuals I don't
know whether or not such collusion
that's your term such collusion existed
I don't know but I know that there was a
sufficient basis of information and
intelligence that required further
investigation by the bureau to determine
whether or not US persons were actively
conspiring colluding with Russian
officials so what Brennan is saying here
is that he was particularly concerned
about the communications between Trump
associates and Russian associates
because Russia tends to bribe and
blackmail people now he is the former
CIA director so he didn't say anything
about what has been determined as a
result of that by the current ongoing
investigations Republicans immediately
tried to frame this as hey Brennan went
up there and said there's no evidence of
collusion no what Brennan said is when
he used to be CIA director here's what
he was aware of and here's why he was
concerned about it he couldn't speak to
whether collusion did or didn't take
place or has been determined to have
taken place the guy is no longer doing
the investigation and it seems like
whenever these intelligence officials
testified to Congress they're always
just confirming news reports from even
months ago yeah and they never come out
with any major blockbusters so it is
surprising that Republicans are trying
to preempt that and trying to get them
to contradict what the media is saying
absolutely and it didn't work I mean
John Brennan was if you watch this you
could tell this guy was not going to be
tricked into saying anything John
Brennan also saying at this hearing
quote frequently individuals who go
along the treasonous path do not even
realize they're along that path until it
gets to be a bit too late which is an
interesting comment to say the least
how did Republicans who had their turn
with Brennan handle it they basically
tried to downplay the investigation
defend Donald Trump they didn't really
do a very good job of it it was pretty
transparent I watched about an hour
yesterday they kept trying to get
Brennan to say there is no evidence of
collusion but Brennan kept repeating I
was concerned by the contact and I can't
judge whether there was or wasn't
collusion Brennan didn't feel qualified
and this is what when you look at
right-wing media after something like
this their headline was Brennan can't
say there's collusion Brennan refuses to
say there's collusion Brennan said he's
not in a position it's like saying if
you bring your mail carrier in and you
question them and you say can you
confirm that there was collusion no I'm
just a mail carrier I can't confirm that
mail carrier says no collusion now what
they said is they're not in a position
to comment on whether there was
collusion and that is what John Brennan
was saying here and Brennan saying I
don't know is just I don't know it's
nothing further than that it's not like
he's saying well I can't really comment
on this in a public setting and you can
see why both sides I guess would try to
twist his words to fit some narrative no
doubt about it but there is some
objective reality about what he did say
and the general idea of the Republicans
is downplay the entire thing like
there's nothing to see here that becomes
more and more difficult to do when we
know that Donald Trump asked the
Director of National Intelligence and
the director of the NSA to publicly lie
and say oh no evidence no collusion
between Trump and Russia Trump asked
former FBI director James Comey to stop
investigating Michael Flynn who's an
important part was an important part of
the investigation then fired Comey
admitting that part of it was to ease
the pressure on him because of the
Russia investigation and now the former
director of the CIA is confirming yeah
there was communication between Trump
and Russia the idea of oh this is all
just completely overblown Republicans
had an opportunity at this hearing you
could even argue that they had a duty to
really question John Brennan in the
service of finding out more about
whether or not the president colluded
with a foreign adversary that's
something that should go beyond politics
but instead these Republicans waste time
with John Brennan playing silly
political games trying to use semantic
tricks on John Brennan trying to make
the investigation look frivolous sweep
everything under the rug Republicans
haven't even been responding with that
disapproval after we found out that
Trump asked the DNI and director of the
NSA to lie to the public and say there's
no evidence of collusion and former CIA
director Brennan also criticized Trump
for sort of blurting out this Israeli
Intel to Russians in the Oval Office
take a look at this other clip from
Brennan's hearing two protocols are one
is that such intelligence classified
intelligence is not shared with visiting
foreign ministers or local ambassadors
it's shared through intelligence
channels because it needs to be handled
the right way and it needs to make sure
that it is not exposed he didn't do that
if again if the press charges are
accurate secondly before sharing any
classified intelligence with foreign
partners it needs to go back to the
originating agency to make sure that the
language in it is not even just
providing a substance going to reveal
sources of methods and compromise the
future collection capability yeah so
what John Brennan is saying there is
your everyday run-of-the-mill spy
recruiting Russian ambassador should not
casually be told about information that
would presumably be handled with extreme
care but that's not what Trump does
because as we know he wanted to brag to
the Russians about the great Intel that
he gets send me your thoughts about John
Brennan send me your thoughts about
Trump lawyering up I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show